[Music]
detective Pikachu or Pokemon detective
Pikachu don't know which ones go it's a
detective Pikachu is a Pokemon movie
it's a live-action Pokemon movie with
CGI Pokemon lives in a world where there
are Pokemon trainers there's a city
where Pokemon and human beings that
coexist live together but then this one
guy goes missing this detective
Pikachu's partner so missing guy's son
teams up with detective Pikachu they're
gonna find it all so Pikachu is voiced
by Ryan Reynolds and that's who carries
the entire movie Ryan Reynolds carries
this thing in fact without Ryan Reynolds
voicing Pikachu I don't think it really
would have worked to be honest some of
the acting in the movie you're like okay
Ryan Reynolds is still great great Ryan
Reynolds does play Ryan Reynolds like
Ryan Reynolds as Pikachu plays Deadpool
just without the curse words and
violence but Deadpool
it's like Robert Downey jr. like at a
point Robert Downey jr. roles for all
just they were Tony Stark and then at a
point he was just Tony Stark because
that's all he did with Marvel movie but
that's Ryan Reynolds like this really
works for Ryan Reynolds and he's great
at it and as I'm watching the movie like
you can tell they're Pokemon references
like I'm not really down with Pokemon
not that I hate Pokemon or anything I
see the appeal for sure but that just
never crossed my path as a thing I
latched on to the most Pokemon exposure
I have definitely Super Smash Brothers
so as I'm watching this movie I'm like
that was a reference a lot of kids in
this auditorium did get it so this
movie's made for Pokemon fans made for
kids made for families I am neither of
those things bit of a manchild some time
sure but generally I'm not the target
demographic but I still had a fun time
with this movie this movie's a fun
adventure with Ryan Reynolds voice
carrying it Ryan Reynolds voice and
Pikachu's cuteness the two go together
kind of like pistachio ice cream you're
like what I thought those two went
together but dammit they do but the
references aren't just like extra
sometimes you're like I have to know who
those are like I know who greninja is
because again smash brothers but if I
was some parent taking my kids who's
just one scene was like oh they
referenced greninja and I could be like
was greninja that was at the Frog or was
that the turtle with the lettuce on his
back that shoots things parents might
get a little confusing this movie
because movie just kind of operates like
will you know who these Pokemon are and
maybe you don't I do call BS on the
physics this is woman Cyr I'm like you
should have died Pokemon world or not
the words of the great Montgomery Scott
you can't change to the laws of physics
not doing a Scottish accent don't make
me try point is that fall would kill
anybody but now I was fine and there was
a seed in this movie these aren't even
critiques these are just observations at
one point I was like that is from the
Tim Burton Batman movie but it's
straight up that's what it is regardless
I was having fun with the adventure
along the way in that family-friendly
kind of way and actually in the third
act of this movie it's kind of intense
like this one mom and her two kids she's
like had her kids by the hands just like
nope like left the auditorium but I
suppose that does show that this movie
does have something for everybody
Pokemon fans kids families it's like one
of those family movies you can take your
kids to would not actually make excuses
be like I got a P for the 14th time
right I feel like the early reports once
again early reports man it's always
hyperbole in it like they're all like
there's just the credit me don't
overcook it it's fun it's good it's
enjoyable in fact I will say detective
Pikachu is a good time no alcohol
requires all right so detective Pikachu
have you seen you know what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you
[Music]